madame monsieur bonsoir et bienvenue ici
au futuroscope pour un premier spectacle
derrière moi le chantier de la reina
futuroscope ce qu'on a voulu faire ce
soir si vous offrir un premier spectacle
à partager tous et toutes et nous allons
vivre et fort je m'appelle david berra
genre le plaisir découvrir ce show cette
présentation
voyez à côté de moi il ya un mur ici on
va poser la première pierre dans
quelques minutes de ce cet aréna du
futuroscope
mais pour poser une première pierre en
fait il nous faut l'outil du maçon est
ce que quelqu'un a une truelle ici oui
allez on va le décorer ensemble une
manière originale de poser cette
première pierre ici sur le site du
futuroscope
[Musique]
pourquoi 3 700 degrés là 700 de béton et
des cinq pires acteurs sont la
fabrication sa courbe absent du tour
minutes j'ai pris l'oreiller langeac
pour raconter vos besoins c'est vrai que
ça consomme un peu quant à la tenue
c'est pas mal filmé par l'apa deux
manches comme on dirige cet appareil
alors cet appareil est dirigée par le
poids de son corps
exactement comme du traître plus
qu'amplement avec la cnaf fait il était
gaz où ils enlèvent des gaz quand
suffisent des russes
alors depuis exactement comme un avion
ce comité est la partie la plus délicate
idole voilà il nous rejoint avec
l'actuel rejoint ce soir au futuroscope
avec la truelle qui va permettre pour
quelques instants
cette pose de la première pierre très
très bien être matériaux docteur premier
spectacle devant ce qui sera l'un des
plus grandes salles pour accueillir du
sport qui se rétractent des loisirs
l'émerveillement et un bon rythme tout
le respect que ce sera également dans
cet aréna très très bientôt